justice Steven barrier obtient la
suspension de sa peine pour 6 mois et ce
pour raison médicales tel en a décidé le
tribunal d'application des peines de
châteurou où est incarcéré Steven
barriet condamné en septembre 2012 à 20
ans de réclusion criminelle pour avoir
participé au meurtre d'Iven Latron
Steven barriet a toujours clamé son
innocence mais il est surtout atteint de
la maladie de crô une grave maladie des
intestins qui lui fait perdre beaucoup
de poids il pèse 35 kg actuellement
c'est donc une première victoire pour
son avocat mais le ministère public a 10
jours pour faire Rael de la décision
sinon Steven barriet pourrait rejoindre
un hôpital parisien la peine serait
suspendue le temps de son
hospitalisation ce n'est donc pas une
fleur qu'on lui fait a déclaré son
avocat Maître Bussy